Have you ever heard about a company called
Oracle?
Within tech circles, Oracle is an industry
classic having been in the business since
1977.
Yet, for the average person, Oracle is a completely
unfamiliar name.
That’s not too surprising though given that
Oracle only has a total 430,000 customers
worldwide.
What’s insane though is that Oracle is valued
at $240 billion, meaning that each Oracle
customer translates to over $550,000 worth
of market cap.
To put that into perspective, Facebook has
a total of 2.89 billion active users, and
they’re valued right at $1 trillion.
This means that each Facebook customer only
translates to $346 worth of market cap or
nearly 1600 times less.
So, here’s how Larry Ellison built his $113
billion fortune with less than half a million
users worldwide.
Taking a look back, Larry Ellison was born
on August 17, 1944 in New York City to a single
mother.
His biological father was a US Army Air Corps
pilot, but it doesn’t really seem like Larry
had much of a relationship with him.
In fact, he didn’t have much of a relationship
with his biological mother either.
When Larry was 9 months old, he caught pneumonia,
and his mother would give Larry to her aunt
and uncle to raise.
These two would basically become Larry’s
parents as Larry wouldn’t even see his biological
mother again until he was 48 years old.
The uncle would give Larry the last name Ellison
as he thought this was a great way to honor
his entry into the US through Ellis island.
As a kid Larry was a pretty bright kid, but
it wasn’t like he was programming at the
age of 12 or anything.
He would end up attending the University of
Illinois as a premed student.
After the first year, he was actually named
the science student of the year, but he would
never end up finishing his studies.
You see, at the end of his second year at
college, his adoptive mother would pass away
and Larry would miss his final exams.
I’m sure he could have arranged to take
the exams at a different time given his circumstances,
but he would decide to just drop out altogether.
Soon after, he would enroll in the University
of Chicago, but Larry would drop out of here
as well after the first semester.
Unlike other tech billionaires, he didn’t
instantly set out on building a tech empire.
In fact, he was pretty lost throughout his
20s.
He did hold several respectable jobs throughout
this time period like a job at Wells Fargo;
however, he was constantly switching around
and didn’t really have any purpose.
He was able to pick up some computer programming
skills throughout this time period though,
and this would prove extremely valuable in
the 1970s.
In 1973, Larry was working at an electronics
company called Ampex, and this is where he
would meet two men named Ed Oates and Bob
Miner.
By 1976 though, Larry would leave Ampex as
well and join Precision Instruments as vice
president.
But this is when Larry would come across a
research paper written by a British computer
scientist named Edgar F. Codd.
In the paper, Codd described how large amounts
of data could be efficiently stored using
a relational database model.
Larry very quickly realized the commercial
potential of such a product and would reach
out to his former colleagues Ed Oates and
Bob Miner about the idea.
The three would get together and start developing
a database solution based on Codd’s research
paper.
It seems like Larry was the most convinced
about the idea though as he fronted $1200
of the total $2000 they started with.
Originally, they named the company Software
Development Laboratories, but by the time
they finished development in 1979, they would
change the name to Relational Software Inc.
In 1979, the trio would launch their database
product which they called Oracle to the public.
Oracle was the first commercial SQL based
relational database program on the market.
But, 1979 was simply way too early for such
a product, and no one really cared.
So, the team had to be extremely aggressive
with their marketing effort and even be a
little sleazy.
One example of this was the naming of the
product itself.
You see, the product wasn’t just called
Oracle, it was actually called Oracle V2 despite
it being the first version.
Larry Ellison figured that people would be
much more likely to buy a second generation
product, so he just went ahead and called
the product V2.
Despite this though, it was still extremely
difficult to make sales because once again,
no one cared at the time.
Fortunately for the team though, the CIA would
give them a shot and become the company’s
first major customer.
Given that the company was only known for
Oracle V2, in 1982, the team would decide
to change the name of the company to Oracle
Systems Corporation.
Over the next couple of years, they would
launch newer versions of Oracle, and as you
would guess each version was 1 off.
Version 2 was called Oracle V3, version 3
was cooled Oracle V4, and so on.
By 1986, Oracle started to gain some serious
traction and they would decide to go public.
At IPO, each share of Oracle was worth $15
which gave the company a valuation of $194
million.
So, not quite a billion dollar company, but
still massive nonetheless.
In 1987, Oracle would become the largest database
management company in the world, but this
would unfortunately be the company’s last
highlight for quite some time.
In 1990, an internal audit would reveal that
Oracle had been overstating their earnings.
It seems like the sales team was counting
orders as sales and this inflated Oracle’s
top line for a few quarters.
Oracle would come out with revised quarterly
reports, and they weren’t half bad, but
investors were not happy nonetheless.
Looking back, you can’t even see this on
Oracle’s stock graph as it was so insignificant
in comparison to Oracle’s stock price today.
But at the time, this scandal led to a 75%
decline in Oracle’s stock price.
Oracle also started to face increasing competition
within the database market as more companies
entered the scene.
As a result, in an effort to diversify and
continue growing, Larry would attempt to take
Oracle into the personal computer market.
He actually had a brilliant idea to reduce
the cost of personal computers by leveraging
databases and networks.
His idea was to create something called the
NC or the network computer.
This computer would basically just be a barebones
screen and input device while the actual computing
and processing would be completed on Oracle’s
networks.
He basically wanted to use cloud computing
to reduce the cost of computers.
But as you might’ve guessed, the technology
just wasn’t there to create such a product
in the 1990s.
Moreover, the cost of personal computers were
plummeting as technology continued to advance,
so it made less and less sense to create the
NC.
By the end of the 1990s, Oracle had made little
progress.
They were still the largest database company
in the world, but the NC didn’t go anywhere
and Oracle now had a major competitor called
Informix.
Around this time though, internet companies
were blowing up as the dotcom bubble picked
up steam.
Larry Ellison would clevely pick up on this
opportunity and embrace the internet.
He would offer Oracle’s various database
and network products through the internet.
In the meantime, Informix would fizzle out
by themselves.
In 1997, Informix would have their own earnings
scandal and the CEO, Phil White, would end
up in jail.
So, Oracle’s major problems would unexpectedly
be solved overnight and this allowed Oracle
to rally exponentially along with the rest
of the dotcom companies.
Between 1999 and 2000, Oracle stock would
grow from just $6 to $40.
But by 2002, they would crash back down to
$10 per share.
Despite their share price crashing, Oracle
was in a better position than ever.
They had little major competition and they
had a new growth venue which was the internet.
Given their strong position in the market,
Oracle would go on a shopping spree, and they’ve
been on a shopping spree ever since.
If you look through their list of acquisitions,
you’ll see that they made 55 acquisitions
between 2000 and 2010 alone.
One of their most famous acquisitions of all
time was Sun Microsystems for $7.4 billion
which gave Oracle control over the Java programming
platform.
Throughout the 2010s, Oracle has basically
just stuck to doing the same thing.
They still provide database solutions and
acquire a bunch of companies, but they have
expanded to cloud services as well which has
proved to be quite lucrative.
But that still leaves the question, how did
Oracle make so much money with such few customers?
Well, the answer is pretty simple, their entire
customer base is enterprises who pay Oracle
massive amounts of money every single year.
And when I say massive, I don’t mean thousands
or even tens of thousands per year.
I’m talking hundreds of thousands and millions
per year.
When we take a look at the size of their customers,
this isn’t that surprising.
For Oracle’s Enterprise Resource Planning
cloud or Oracle ERP, 48% of their customers
make less than $50 million per year, 10% make
between $50 million and $1 billion per year,
and 30% make over $1 billion per year.
Basically every single company and organization
you can think of uses Oracle or has used them
in the past.
Everyone from Netflix, Google, Amazon, Walmart,
Chase, MIT, governments, JetBlue, Dell, eBay,
you get the point.
Basically everyone.
Considering this, it’s not surprising that
Oracle is worth $245 billion today.
In fact, I’m surprised that it’s not worth
more given the massive valuations of other
tech companies.
Right now, Oracle only has a PE ratio of 19.31
which is the lowest I’ve seen in the tech
industry recently.
But anyway, going back to Larry Ellison, he
stepped down from being Oracle’s CEO in
2014 after 37 years, but he still owns 35%
of the company today.
This translates to about $85 billion.
But Larry is actually worth $113 billion today
due to a variety of other investments.
He has over a billion in real estate and he
used to have a multi billion dollar position
in Netsuite.
Aside from this, it’s also believed that
he has a large position in SalesForce, but
this has not been confirmed.
Larry also owns Oracle team USA which is a
yacht racing team who have won several America’s
cups.
However, by far his most famous investment
was in December of 2018, when he bought 3
million shares of Tesla.
Adjusting for the stock split, that’s the
same as 15 million shares of Tesla today.
Right after he bought it, he actually got
screwed as Tesla crashed 50 percent in early
2019.
But as we all know, Tesla has since recovered
and soared to unbelievable heights.
Larry’s stake in Tesla is now worth over
$10 billion and he’s actually a Tesla board
member today.
And that’s the story of how Larry Ellison
made $113 billion with less than half a million
customers.
Did you guys know about Larry Ellison?
Comment that down below.
Also, drop a like if you’re impressed by
Oracle’s massive background role.
And of course, consider joining our discord
community to suggest future video ideas and
consider subscribing to see more questions
logically answered.